hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are continuing
with the match Magnus Carlsen versus
Maxie Marshall agraja
and this is Game three Game two ended in
a draw and the max team is still down
one point so he needs the win to get
back into the match so Magnus again with
the white pieces he opens up now with d4
so he doesn't try to repeat that Bishop
to c4 line to avoid the neither from
Game one
we have d5 by maksim not going for his
groom felt he is now obviously a slot
man
we have c4 and c6 the Slav defenses on
the board with III in the knight to f6
with Knight to c3 and again Bishop to a5
this time a bit different as in that
game Armageddon game against ding-ding
had this night out Knight not this one
so it is a bit different but okay Knight
to f3 and now E six again now closing
the position now that the bishop has
been developing and Magnus immediately
goes after the bishop which is the most
popular way it is played nowadays so
Bishop the e4 e we have f3 kicking the
bishop back push up to g6 and now my
bishop today to continue just to develop
Bishop e7 and out Magna straight with
Knight captures H captures and the Queen
to b3 now going for the b7 pawn queen to
c7 defending by maksim and here a
queenside castle by Magnus a we have d
cap resin c4 Bishop captures and b5 now
starting to expand on the Queen side
russia-backed to e2 and a6 now so Magnus
retains the bishop parent where as
Maxime does have well this nice Queen
side expansion going for him and he
still has to decide where his Kings two
will stay in the center of the board or
will will he he himself Castle so nice
to e4 by Magnus again putting some
pressure on the night here
Magnus maxime trades with Knight
captures F captures now with a lot of
central control for Magnus here and he
did the he does have a double D pawn now
but on the other hand he also had the
semi open F file to use for his rook so
c5 by maksim he starts attacking on the
Queen side and King to be one just
getting the King out of the way now and
now
it's a question whether you wanna push
c4 or not here
nice the c6 maxime weights with it and
here there actually are two games that
reach this exact same position in both
of them d5 was played but here
Magnus goes for e5 and it is a new move
in the position which seems to come with
the price of a pawn as Maxine just
captures it C captures on d4 and Magnus
just continues developing Bishop to f3
now puts pressure here and you will have
to do something about it you cannot move
the knight you hang the rook the king is
still in the center of the board so here
if you if you continue just grabbing
material we will have Queen captures on
e3 and after the rook moves rook to c1
will put a lot of pressure here so then
the Queen can move you can add more
pressure and so on so instead of
grabbing more material Maxime goes for
rook to see it right away and not rook
the c1 by Magnus again putting pressure
on the night here with the rook and the
bishop so Queen d7 and the now Queen to
c2 getting adding yet another attacker
to d2 the c6 Knight and here there's
only one move for maxim knight the a7
now opening up an attack from the rook
to the queen but Magnus just captures
that Queen captures on c8 this comes
with check and now what do you do do you
capture with the Queen or do you capture
with the knight capturing with the Queen
does seem to to save you in any exchange
sacrifices however after rook captures
Knight captures you're gonna get better
the c6 check and after the King moves
wherever you're gonna go Bishop e7 and
you're gonna start winning some points
here nice to be six you're gonna capture
here on d4 then this is a target and
it's just well it's just a better
position for white so here instead of
instead of deciding to give up pawns the
Maxime captures with the night and now
brush up the c6
the he wins back the Queen this way
Knights to b6 and now the Bishop
captures on b7 King capture Sun d7 and
now he captures on d4 so now it's a
little bit different as now Maxine is
down the exchange but he is obviously
happier with this position than the one
we've shown
the d5 getting his knife to a nice
central outpost and now Magnus plays h4
and he played it too very quickly and I
thought what's h4 I mean what is this
obviously okay you can't capture with
the better because g3 just wins material
as the rook on h8 would hang if you move
the bishop but Maxime also not really
not really getting it or probably
captures her with the rook and I was
also very surprised when I saw this
because Magnus just trades and after
Bishop captures he plays the rook to h1
probably with the idea that if Bishop
moves you're just gonna go after the
pawn this way or maybe you want to
infiltrate and get to the Queen side
this way but I thought that doesn't g5
just fix all of that well not really had
Maxine played the g5 then Magnus has
rook h3 threatening to trap the bishop
with g3 and once the bishop moves and f2
is your only square now rook a 3 again
with the double attack on the bishop and
on the f7 pawn so once you capture on
before then comes rook captures on f7
you lose this and it's just a just a
capture fest so there was a point to the
h4 pawn sacrifice so Maxine goes back
back up to East 7 and now look the h7
going after this point Maxime defends it
and now we have looked the h8 attacking
the bishop or if the bishop moves just
going after the points on the Queen side
King the East 7 and the now comes King
to see to Magnus starts bringing the
King inter game with f6 and now e
captures on f6 with check we have G
captures on f6
if you go Knight captures then we just
have a nice Bishop to b4 check winning
the game on the spot as there's now a
double attack would be under on the
bishop on f8 there so after a captures
on f6 with G captures on f6 and here
Magnus played rook to h7 check and it
was in this position unmoved 32 that
maxime beaugeois ground the game and
that is it for this match Magnus wins
the match for the game will be played of
course as it is required for to
calculate additional criteria at the end
of the tournament but here he just
resigns he he could play on I guess a
little bit but he is very very sure that
Magnus will be able to win this and he
just resigned
so thing is after the King moves for
example King be six you're gonna go
after these pawns and let's not forget
you're still at the exchange yes you're
down upon but you will start winning
them back and the problem is you cannot
defend with Knight here because again
Bishop before check wins the bishop on
f8 so that's the problem so you will not
be able to defend the a six point you're
gonna have to play something they'll
start pushing your pawn but then he just
start losing them rook captures with
checking d7 you're gonna get B 3 a4 is
coming to create a passed pawn for white
and well Maxime was very sure that there
was no point in continuing this so after
rook h7 checked he resigned the game so
really really impressive stuff again the
seemingly effortless by Magnus is just
destroying the the Slav defense and
finding that tricky tricky after Knight
a7 Queen captures on c8 idea and I don't
know why man why Maxime decided that it
would be maybe better to play this and
exchange down rather than give up a pawn
but he he is the expert so probably he
knew that the positions that would come
up from that line would just be too too
easy for Magnus to play nobody are
really exciting stuff that's game 3 I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Frank truce Louis F rivers a poll
are Hansen Antonio Vecchio and Robert a
vote klonda for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational until it finishes so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and do join
the tournaments that are in the
description below so thank you I will
see you soon and like I said have an
external rest of your day